a film about the future inspired by the
past the sequel That Never Was and two
Hollywood Legends finally joined forces
let's Dive Into The Inspirations and
creative minds behind Minority Report
years before Steven Spielberg and Tom
Cruise brought Minority Report to the
big screen audiences almost saw a
radically different version of this
project per Gizmodo Philip K Dick's
short story Minority Report was optioned
in the 1990s for a feature film that
would be helmed by Total Recall director
Paul verhoven when looking over the
story verhoven felt it would be the
perfect material for a sequel to his
1990 film Total Recall the connection
between these two sci-fi properties
wasn't completely random as Total Recall
was based on another Philip K dick story
we can remember it for you wholesale
from there the follow-up began to move
quickly into production with Total
Recall leading man Arnold Schwarzenegger
agreeing to come back for the sequel
however just as the project was getting
off the ground the production company in
charge of the feature went bankrupt the
script then got snagged by 20th Century
Fox who decided to make a standalone
Minority Report movie that didn't have
any connection to Total Recall this
eventually LED led to Spielberg's take
on Minority Report which was co-produced
by 20th Century Fox while the final
version of Minority Report garnered
widespread Acclaim fans of Total Recall
are doubtlessly disappointed they never
got a sequel to this film
consider that a divorce
Minority Report wasn't just another Tom
Cruise action movie nor was it just
another sci-fi film helmed by Steven
Spielberg this was a momentous moment in
the career of both of these men as it
finally gave Cruz and Spielberg a chance
to work with each other it was no
coincidence that the duo was finally
making a movie together either as they
had been trying to unite forces for
years speaking to Entertainment Weekly
Spielberg recalled how he had first met
Cruz on the set of Risky Business back
in the early 1980s right then and there
the spark began to form between the two
and they were determined to work
together Crews put it plainly I just
knew I wanted to work with the guy even
back then he was Steven Spielberg the
guy who did E.T and Raiders of the law
start years went by however as they kept
trying to figure out the perfect project
to join forces on things almost came
together for them when Spielberg was set
to direct Crews on 1988's Rain Man
however Spielberg had to depart from the
film because of scheduling conflicts
with Indian Jones and the Last Crusade
but he never gave up on his Ambitions of
directing a Tom Cruise picture
eventually Cruz brought Minority Report
to Spielberg and suddenly the project
they had been waiting for came to
fruition finally there was a production
that United an iconic director with an
equally iconic actor
at the dawn of the 21st century
speculation was running rampant over
what would be the next Steven Spielberg
directorial effort the filmmaker's last
film had been the 1998 feature saving
project Ryan which scored Spielberg a
Best Director Oscar win for the second
time and was one of the highest grossing
films of the Year via Box Office Mojo
these Feats combined with the man's
reputation as one of the most acclaimed
and successful directors ever meant that
all eyes were on where he would go next
plans to have Minority Report film in
the first year of the 21st century were
scuttled in March 2000 when it was
announced that Spielberg would be
helming AI artificial intelligence first
via BBC News AI was a production that
had been lingering on Spielberg's to-do
list for years but it took precedence
once Stanley Kubrick who wrote the
screenplay for AI passed away in March
1999. Kubrick had spent decades writing
Ai and this combined with the deep bond
he and Spielberg shared inspired
Spielberg to make this film a priority
so the start date of Minority Report got
pushed to April 2001 which meant it
would not have the honor of being
Spielberg's first directorial effort of
the new century
while Tom Cruise was always set to
Anchor the world of Minority Report as
the protagonist John anderton several
other actors came and went from the film
supported cast throughout its production
many of these were massive names who
could have been right at home with the
level of prestige associated with Cruz
and Steven Spielberg one such person was
Matt Damon who was approached to play a
character who has a kinship with Jon but
then is forced to hunt him down when Jon
is pre-accused of murder per USA Today
Damon was interested in the part and has
been recent Oscar win for writing
Goodwill Hunting would have made him
inappropriately acclaimed artist for
such a star-studded project plus Damon
and Spielberg had already worked
together once before on the box office
Juggernaut Saving Private Ryan while
Damon was dying to reunite with this
filmmaker it was never meant to be
scheduling conflicts prevented him from
joining crews in Minority Report Damon
was already on the line to do Ocean's 11
and the filming schedule for that Steven
Soderbergh Ensemble piece directly
conflicted with Minority Report with
that Minority report began to look
around for someone else to take on the
role instead which eventually went to
Colin Farrell
Minority Report was filmed in the summer
of 2001 and wrapped just a few months
before the terrorist attacks of
September 11th would forever alter the
United States of America in the wake of
such devastating Horrors it was
inevitable for people to read new 911
relevant layers into pieces of art that
were never meant to comment on this
historical event when it came to
Minority Report even director Steven
Spielberg was well aware of this
speaking to the New Zealand Herald
Spielberg was upfront about how a film
like Minority Report which is about
policing and privacy would register with
people in the wake of 9 11. he noted
that the film mirrored how authorities
were rounding up people in real life to
get information and prevent future
atrocities saying I feel that history
has caught up with our imagination and
given us a cold soak of reality
if there's a flaw it's human
it always is
in many ways Minority Report was a movie
that could only exist in the 21st
century namely with its digital effects
Wizardry and its use of then-freshed
face Talent like Colin Farrell and
Samantha Morton but it's also a feature
rooted deeply in one of the great film
genres of the 20th century Noir film
Noir which literally means black film
often focuses on stories of Lone
protagonists who must endure in the face
of society's gone Haywire due to moral
corruption so it's easy easy to see why
Minority Report would fit into the
Hallmarks of the genre but to ensure
that Minority Report lived up to all of
its potential Spielberg opted to do a
crash course in the all-time greats of
the Noir landscape before he started
shooting this High concept Tom Cruise
vehicle he told Entertainment Weekly
that he thoroughly dug into the classics
of the genre asphalt jungle Key Largo
and the Maltese Falcon were the movies
he turned to while molding his vision
for Minority Report he also noted that
he tried to embrace the darker edges of
the genre to counter his quote
sentimental side
oh my gosh are you okay
much like our own modern world the
universe that Minority Report inhabits
is one defined by technology not only is
the futuristic Tech used to prevent
crimes before they even happen but
virtual AIDS show up all over the place
while spider robots are used to hunt
down lethal criminals this is a world
defined by machines even more than by
the men that made them because of their
importance to the story Steven Spielberg
was very careful about the role
technology would play in Minority Report
and how it would be realized according
to Entertainment Weekly Spielberg
gathered a group of futurists and asked
them to brainstorm a plausible vision of
what life in 2054 could be like talking
to Roger Ebert Spielberg elaborated that
his goal with Minority Report was to
make a movie where all the futuristic
Tech shown on screen could eventually
become a reality this informed some
hopeful details about minority report's
vision of what's to come including the
idea of a transportation system that
isn't as harmful to the environment
simultaneously he wanted to present an
eerie quality to the intrusive nature of
futuristic advertising Spielberg said of
his own beliefs about what would become
reality in the future television will be
watching us and customizing itself to
what it knows about us the thrilling
thing is that will make us feel we're
part of the media the scary thing is
we'll lose our right to privacy this
dichotomy gets reflected in various
spots in minority reports which both
demonstrates how far media and consumer
materials have come and also how nobody
has privacy in the society portrayed on
screen
in the summer of 2002 both George Lucas
and Steven Spielberg released new
directorial efforts that were costly
action Blockbusters Lucas debuted Star
Wars Attack of the Clones which heavily
utilized digital sets in contrast
Spielberg's Minority Report primarily
employed practically realized
backgrounds even though this mystery
takes place in the future Spielberg
still went throughout of building
elaborate sets that the actors could see
and feel as they shot film talking to
Roger Ebert Spielberg expressed
admiration for Attack of the Clones and
all that Lucas had accomplished with his
digital sets however Spielberg also said
that he was hoping to never get to the
point where he was shooting movies that
would involve just green screens and CGI
sets this was in part because physical
sets stimulate and Inspire the actors on
Minority Report Spielberg was insistent
that practical sets be used whenever
possible even seemingly impossible
pieces of camera work such as the
overhead shot of the robotic spiders
entering the building where John
assigned were realized through onset
Ingenuity rather than post-production
digital Wizardry Spielberg's commitment
to old-school production design choices
ensured that the world of Minority
Report reverberated with tangibility and
Grit
perhaps more distinct than any of the
fight scenes or explosions in Minority
Report is the look of the entire feature
the visual style of Minority Report is
unique and feels drained of color which
complements the Grim atmosphere of the
film talking to the New York Times
Steven Spielberg noted that he used a
process called bleach bypassing to
achieve this effect bleach bypassing is
done in post-production and drains out
the color from people's faces now
instead of having cheeks and skin tones
that radiate warmth everyone in Minority
Report has pale faces which helps to
accentuate their constantly intense and
paranoid meaners Spielberg noted that
touches like this insured an old-school
grainy appearance that made it feel more
like the noir films of old the result
was that Minority Report combined older
looking techniques and styles that were
seen predominantly in the 1940s with a
modern tale and technology which truly
made it look like no other movie out
there
Minority Report arrived in theaters with
lots of hype thanks to its collaboration
between Tom Cruise and director Steven
Spielberg the melding of these Hollywood
Titans excited film fans but there was
also some concern wafting in the air
around its release chiefly this was an
unusual Blockbuster in the summer of
2002 and this was a season dominated by
light-hearted Star Wars Adventures and
the first Spider-Man movie so you won't
help me I can't help you nobody can but
in the end Minority Report did manage to
secure
358.8 million dollars worldwide more
than tripling its sizable 102 million
dollar budget this feature also came in
a head of other notable Spielberg titles
globally such as Indiana Jones and the
Temple of Doom and Close Encounters of
the Third Kind if there was a complaint
to be had here it's that Minority
reports did get overshadowed by several
other 2002 movies while it was the 10th
biggest film of the year worldwide
domestically minority report was in 17th
Place it even came in behind titles like
Signs and XXX while it didn't Crush all
other 2002 movies Minority Report was
still a profitable exercise reinforcing
that Spielberg Blockbusters can always
draw a mighty crowd
[Music]